i'm billy mitchell video game player of
the century
i did the world's first perfect score on
pac-man 3 million thirty three thousand
three hundred and sixty oh it's
exhausting to just say it
i began in the competitive world of
pinball
it moved to donkey kong
but the greatest level of competition at
the moment was pac-man
if i was going to be the best i had to
be the best at the game that was
everywhere so in 1999 i sent out a press
release i was as cocky as could be they
said there's been 10 billion games
played how are you going to do it i says
because i'm billy mitchell
you start off on the first board but on
board 21 that's where it reaches maximum
difficulty you have to navigate all the
way to board 255
doing the same repetitive thing you
can't miss a dot a prize a blue man you
can't die once
you can't lose focus you gotta stay with
it all the way there four to five hours
you have to take a corner down to one
sixtieth of a second
in order to create perfect timing and
keep your eye right here right here
you have to do that over 29 000 times
without making any mistakes and dying
you play 255 boards on 256 there's
enough memory left in the game for the
left half of the board and not the right
half
the right half is filled with computer
garble anything and everything that is
not packed in different walls different
dots
that's what a perfect score is
the moment that score went up there
i thought wow
i achieved perfection
you get to the end there's nothing to do
but die there was nothing saying
congratulations there was nothing saying
the end game over nothing the designer
of pac-man
not only did he never think anyone would
get to the end he didn't know where the
end was
he didn't know at what point the game
would run out of memory everything to
him is completely baffling they never
saw the split screen until i sent it to
them
messiah nakamura who's the godfather of
video games
he crowned me video game player of the
century for that and all the previous
achievements
it doesn't get any higher than that